good morning Hank it's Tuesday I
recently became intensely interested in
a question what was the most recent year
in which the overall global population
of humans declined I don't even remember
why I was initially curious about this
but I was and I couldn't figure it out
despite some pretty deep googling and a
visit to the library so eventually I
asked max roser who works at my favorite
web site our world and data but he
didn't know either one of his colleagues
however Hannah Richie did find an answer
the last time the global human
population decreased year over year was
1648 and the story of 1648 turns out to
be really interesting and also like
relevant ok so the global human
population actually decreased every year
between 1608 and 1648 part of a period
sometimes known as the general crisis
which I would say is an example of
historians being terrible at naming
things except that it was a rather
general crisis from Africa to Asia to
Europe to the Americas there was quite a
lot of crisis going on which is a little
weird because overall the human species
was getting much wealthier and better
connected like for instance there was
much more silver because European
empires especially the Spanish Empire
were extracting it from colonies in the
Americas
there was also a much broader range of
food available rice and wheat had just
come to the Americas and everything from
pineapples to cassava to potatoes had
come to afro-eurasia and you would think
with more money and more food there
would be more people but no for one
thing the Columbian Exchange also
brought devastation perhaps more than
90% of Native Americans were killed in
the centuries after Europeans arrived
mostly from diseases that were new to
the Americas like smallpox and
diphtheria that population decline began
around 1500 but lasted throughout the
general crisis and then there was the
Atlantic slave trade which was growing
throughout the general crisis with
horrific consequences of its own around
15 percent of Africans died in slave
ships on the journey to the Americas and
those who didn't saw their life
expectancies severely diminished and I
think it's worth noting that many of the
crops that relied on slave labor like
coffee and tobacco were not necessary to
sustain human life
they were basically luxury goods so
maybe more access to luxury goods
indicated that humanity was getting
wealthier but that doesn't necessarily
mean that on average
human life was getting better in fact
despite the influx of wealth European
populations were also declining largely
due to the 30 Years War one of the
longest and deadliest wars in European
history which is really saying something
the war killed through combat and famine
around 20% of people in what is now
Germany and as many as a third of people
in what are now Poland and Lithuania
meanwhile Spain which had become
phenomenally wealthy from all that
silver defaulted on its debts repeatedly
during the general crisis because they
didn't understand inflation and all that
silver caused a lot of it but the single
biggest contributor to 17th century
population decline was the collapse of
the Ming Dynasty in China between 1600
and 1644 when the Ching dynasty began
China's population decreased by 50
million people and that was also partly
due to humanity's newfound abundance of
silver the Ming government required
people to pay taxes in silver which
meant more people had to spend more
hours working at making goods that could
be sold for silver which meant lower
agricultural yields also the Ming
Dynasty like Spain failed to understand
inflation all of which led to famine one
more thing that made the general crisis
so general and crisis II at the time
earth experienced significant climate
change it's sometimes called the Little
Ice Age global temperatures dropped on
average around one degree Celsius which
also contributed to famines but don't
worry it's not like oh it is like Hank
since the general crisis humanity has
experienced its longest ever run of
population growth increased life
expectancy and decreased poverty but the
early 17th century is a reminder that
progress is never simple or universal or
guaranteed it's a reminder that a
changing climate can fuel global
instability and that growing
connectivity and wealth is only good
news for humans once we learn to live
with and share that growth Hank I'll see
you on Friday